hola a todos lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es describir cómo es que pensamos
las gráficas en tres dimensiones y las
gráficas en tres dimensiones digamos son
una forma de representar algunos tipos
de funciones multi variables muy bien y
este tipo de funciones tiene dos
entradas verdad tendrá dos entradas
vamos a escribir esto bien tendrá dos
entradas y solo un número como salida
verdad entonces digamos la gráfica que
tenemos aquí es exactamente la gráfica
de la función x cuadrada más que
cuadrada muy bien y antes de empezar a
hablar
digamos con más detalle de esta gráfica
me gustaría hacer una analogía que va a
ser muy útil cuando hablamos de gráficas
en dos dimensiones así que vamos a hacer
una pequeña división aquí vamos a hacer
una división aquí y hagamos una
comparación con lo que ya sabemos de las
gráficas
dos dimensiones entonces pongamos
nuestro eje horizontal pongamos nuestro
eje vertical y quizás lo debería poner
más o menos por aquí ahí lo tenemos y en
realidad es muy parecido a lo que ya
teníamos en dos dimensiones lo mismo va
a ocurrir en tres dimensiones son lo que
necesitamos un poquito más de digamos de
visualización así que las gráficas en
dos dimensiones digamos tenemos alguna
función por aquí digamos que vamos a
graficar efe de x igual a x cuadrada
esta va a ser nuestra función y cada vez
que visualizamos una función tratamos de
entender la relación que hay entre las
entradas y las salidas de esta función y
justamente aquí verdad tendríamos
digamos dos números verdad la entrada y
la salida así que digamos si nosotros le
damos un número de entrada digamos vamos
a darle el 2 entonces tendremos como
salida el número 4 si le damos de
entrada menos 1 tendremos de salida el
número
una verdad entonces la idea de las
gráficas es tratar de entender todas las
posibles parejas verdad de entradas con
salidas y el hecho de que hagamos esta
verdad en realidad nos da una muy buena
intuición una una buena sensación de
cómo son todas las relaciones entre
entradas y salidas verdad y esto es
bastante increíble y la forma en la que
pensamos a estas gráficas es justamente
graficar todas estas parejas que
podríamos formar verdad así que lo que
vamos a hacer es digamos graficar
primero el punto 2,4 digamos aquí está
el 1 el 2 aquí estará el 1
3 y 4 y entonces graphic amos este punto
ahora si quisiéramos graficar la otra
pareja verdad menos 1 1 tendríamos que
irnos aquí menos 1 y pondríamos el
número 1 muy bien entonces si pensamos
en todas las posibles parejas de
entradas y salidas que podríamos obtener
tendríamos una una gráfica una una
especie de curva que espero que me salga
más o menos bien una curva que más o
menos debería verse suave verdad debería
verse lisa y la implicación de haber
hecho esto es que típicamente pensamos
que en el eje x se encuentra digamos es
digamos el espacio en donde viven todas
las entradas verdad por ejemplo aquí
tendríamos el 1 aquí tendríamos el 2
aquí podríamos poner el 3 verdad aquí
estaría al menos 1 verdad ahí es en
donde viven todas las posibles entradas
y cuando pensamos en las salidas en
realidad estamos pensando en la altura
verdad en la altura que tenemos para
una de estas entradas y así tenemos
digamos como consecuencia el hecho de
que estamos en listando todas las
parejas verdad en esta gráfica que
estamos pintando estamos enlistando
todas las parejas que podríamos formar
de entradas con salidas ahora si nos
vamos al mundo de las funciones de
varias variables entonces sabemos que no
vamos a mostrar digamos vamos a quitar
ahorita la gráfica ahorita y sólo
pensemos en el espacio de tres
dimensiones que tenemos a nuestra
disposición muy bien entonces queremos
entender la relación que hay entre las
entradas y las salidas de esta función
que tenemos aquí cierto entonces en este
caso las entradas son algo que pensamos
como parejas de puntos que podríamos
pensar como digamos la pareja 1,2 así
que vamos a hacer la pareja 12 verdad
tendremos la pareja 12 como entrada y
vamos a obtener una salida esta salida
será 1 al cuadrado
2 al cuadrado y esto definitivamente es
uno más 4 que nos da justamente 5 muy
bien entonces una foco como podríamos
visualizar esto bueno una forma de de
relacionar todas estas cosas digamos de
forma natural es pensar en tercias de
alguna forma así que en este caso lo que
vamos a tener es una tercia verdad una
tercia que será el punto
como 2,5
esta es la forma en la que vamos a
relacionarlo en tres dimensiones
así que fijémonos por un momento en este
en esta parte verdad y ahora si queremos
visualizar esto en tres dimensiones
tenemos que irnos hacia acá vamos a
movernos uno en la dirección x es decir
a paralelo al eje x verdad y ahora nos
movemos 2 en la dirección
ok siguiendo de forma paralela el eje ye
y luego subimos 5 verdad y eso es lo que
nos va a dar este punto que estamos
graficando verdad así que pensamos este
punto en el espacio que está dado
digamos por una pareja de entrada con
salida y por supuesto si hacemos un
montón de estos podríamos tener un
montón de puntos verdad y así podemos
empezar a graficar distintas de estas de
estas tercios verdad y por supuesto aquí
podríamos tener una infinidad de todas
de todos estos puntos nos llevaría una
eternidad dibujarlos todos pero si si
digamos pensamos en dibujar cada uno de
estos puntos en las tres dimensiones que
tenemos lo bonito aquí es que si
imaginamos haciendo todo esto para toda
la infinidad de parejas
con salidas que podríamos tener
terminamos dibujando una superficie en
este caso la superficie se parece
digamos como una parábola en tres
dimensiones verdad y en realidad no es
casualidad eso tiene que ver con el
hecho de que estamos usando x cuadrada y
cuadrada en nuestra función y ahora las
entradas digamos como el punto 12 que
estamos pensando aquí se encuentran
justamente en el plano xy verdad así que
si pensamos que las entradas viven en
este plano entonces a lo que corresponde
la salida es justamente a la altura en
cada uno de estos puntos sobre la
gráfica verdad así que es en realidad
muy muy parecido a lo que tenemos en dos
dimensiones así que solo para dar un
ejemplo de digamos la consecuencia que
podemos tener aquí si si pensamos por
ejemplo qué ocurriría si cambiamos
nuestra función digamos de varias
variables que teníamos aquí vamos a
cambiarlo un poquito vamos a cambiar un
poquito y ahora vamos a multiplicar todo
a la mitad es decir vamos a considerar
la función
que sea la mitad de x cuadrada más
cuadrada esa es la que vamos a
considerar en este caso ahora nos
podríamos preguntar qué es lo que va a
pasar con la forma de esta función y lo
que significa en realidad es que la
altura de cada punto sobre sobre el
plano x va a estar cortado a la mitad
así que esta es la modificación que
vamos a tener y que estamos observando
aquí verdad tenemos que todo va a bajar
digamos a la mitad de la altura a la que
estaba así que en este caso digamos si
la altura era 5 ahora será 2.5 y puedes
imaginar que bueno podríamos poner un
caso todavía más extremo verdad digamos
que en vez de poner un medio pongamos un
12 a una doceava parte de x cuadrada más
que cuadrada muy bien entonces todo esto
se vuelve muy muy parecido digamos algo
plano se vuelve muy plano muy cercano al
9 x así que la gráfica ahora va a estar
muy cerca al plano xy justamente porque
corresponde a salidas muy pequeñas y una
cosa que quisiera advertir de que en
realidad no siempre es válido es que es
muy tentador pensar en en cada función
multi variable como una gráfica porque
en realidad estamos muy acostumbrados a
las gráficas en dos dimensiones verdad y
a tratar de hallar analogías entre las
dos dimensiones y las tres dimensiones
directamente pero la única razón por la
cual esto funciona es porque tomamos el
número de dimensión de la entrada en
este caso serían dos dimensiones verdad
y el número de dimensiones en las
salidas que es una dimensión y es
razonable encajar todo esto en tres
dimensiones verdad que podríamos hacerlo
pero si imaginamos que tenemos una
función multi variable que digamos tiene
una entrada digamos tridimensional y una
salida de dos dimensiones entonces eso
requeriría una gráfica de cinco
dimensiones y en realidad hay muchos
otros métodos para visualizar todo esto
que yo creo que es muy importante que
digamos
nuestra mente para para todos ellos en
particular vamos a ver digamos por
ejemplo cuando tenemos gráficas en tres
dimensiones vamos a tratar de ver todo
esto en un arreglo de dos dimensiones y
vamos a fijarnos muy bien cómo es el
espacio de entradas a esa visualización
le vamos a llamar curvas de nivel y
vamos a ver otro par digamos funciones
paramétricas donde en realidad nos vamos
a fijar solamente en el espacio de
salida vamos a pensar digamos en campos
vectoriales verdad donde vamos a
fijarnos en el espacio de entrada pero
al mismo tiempo vamos a revisar las
salidas en cada punto verdad y hay un
montón de formas de visualizar todo esto
que que veremos en los próximos vídeos
así que aquí tuvimos gráficas
tridimensionales